[Music]
my name is B poter I'm the direct of
place at District Council I'm Andrea PL
and I'm the head of property at District
Council Council recovery on the leader
of plan District coun when I think about
the Winter Gardens I think about a
delicate balance between preserving its
Rich Heritage and prioritizing sea front
location the Winter Gardens is an
absolutely amazing building
um and it's integral to the history of
Margate the story of marget so we we
really need to find a way to protect the
building for the future and to
reinvigorate the the Fantastic
architecture that was here I was really
excited to see the Heritage significant
statement um that talks about the
original 1911 building and the important
additions that were made in the 1930s
and and I'd really like to see um some
examples of how those could be brought
back to life my personal View and
aspiration for the Winter Gardens would
be reinstating the seaf facing Windows
this will not only honor its original
design but it will give customers and
visitors a chance to immerse themselves
in the breathtaking cvus that we have
here I think I'd like it to be very
recognizable as as the Winter Gardens of
the past actually and I think that's
what the community wants from it but
with a more modern feel to it in terms
of what people expect from their Leisure
experience these days well we're really
Keen to um generate as much interest as
we possibly can and attract as many
different ideas to come forward we want
to hold open days and invite people to
come in and see the building and explore
the building and think about how they
can work with the building and reimagine
it and um and then we'll be seeking
expressions of Interest we want to look
at those expressions of Interest
identify the ones we really like the
ones that um are in in line with our um
Ambitions for the building um
particularly around its Heritage
importance but also um about the
commercial ideas and the Leisure ideas
that those proposals bring forward and
then we'll be inviting those
organizations to provide much more
detail about their proposals so that we
can make a final decision we won't
consider uses which we don't think
comply with the uh Heritage of the
Winter Gardens and we won't allow
changes that we think undermine it it's
a grade two list building that imposes
limitations on what we can do to change
it and um we don't want to change the
building in terms of how people
understand it but we do want to make it
work better for the community the
council already categorically ruled out
any residential uses um at the Winter
Gardens and so we definitely will not be
selling uh the building or the grounds
for the housing that is something that
we have been very clear about housing is
not in line with our vision for this
building so housing is not a an option
that will be support
there's no chance whatsoever that the
council will be um selling the Winter
Gardens for housing using the site for
housing or Pro progressing it for
housing in any shape or forth right at
the beginning of this process we've
removed anything of Heritage
significance anything that was important
to us uh and anything that was
Irreplaceable we have removed it uh
initially and we have put it in safe
storage anything that's still got life
is going to be put into an auction so we
are not throwing anything away that
could still be used or repurposed
anywhere else I just think it's a really
exciting opportunity for for Margate for
the for the council for the district as
a whole for the community because you
know it's a wonderful building with a
wonderful history and it's up to us to
give it a wonderful future and that's
what we're going to try and
[Music]
do